tis the season for holiday game updates
and over watches winter wonderland is
live right now I'm Tony and this is your
festive GameSpot news update
first things first winter wonderland
adds some great new skins to the game
including a peppermint Sombra yeti
winston and at long last santa claus
Torbjorn you might be lucky enough to
get one of those in the game's new gift
wrapped loot boxes which also contain
new sprays voice lines and victory poses
the event also brings a new arcade game
called maze snowball Offensive everyone
plays Ismay and they can only fire off
one snowball at a time you'll have to
reload at a snow pile if your aim isn't
on point
winter wonderland runs from now through
January 2nd overwatch made GameSpot's
list of the top 5 PC games of 2016 you
can check out the rest of our picks
right now and tune into our game of the
year livestream on Tuesday December 20th
at 10 a.m. Pacific will have all sorts
of special guests and prizes for you
there for all the latest on overwatch
you're already in the right place